via the live stream we'll be able to see
each of us on screen individually
please announce yourself by name
when speaking and if you want to refer
to anything in the offices report can
you please first clearly state the
relevant page number and paragraph
number
thank you leslie we're we're ready to uh
to start
okay thank you
welcome everybody
to rochford district councilman of the
audit committee
and welcome to anyone watching this via
live stream
agenda item one
apologies for absence
apologies for absence have been received
from councillors
tony carter
ireland godson
james gooding
tracy knight
and phil shaw
are there any others
no counselor counselor mrs laurean
agenda item 2 substitute members
councillor christine mason for
councillor tony carter
councillor joe mcpherson
for councillor ireland gadson
councillor arthur williams for
councillor james gooding
councillor michael hoy
for councillor tracy knight
councillor daniel lefty
for councillor phil shaw
agenda item three non-members attending
council and mrs butcher we have uh
councillors smith and councillor watson
in attendance
thank you
agenda item 4
minutes of the meeting held on the 28th
of september 2021
are the minutes of the meeting held on
the 28th of september 2021 agreed
members
i would assume so unless anyone clicks
on the raise hand icon
so they are agreed
agenda item 5
to receive declarations of interests
members are there any declarations of
interest
no
agenda item six
financial statements 2020
2021
members we have debbie hansen and
hussein gulen from the council's
external auditors
ernst young in attendance this evening
naomi lucas assistant director resources
can you please introduce the report
thank you chair
um yeah as you've just said um we've got
um
uh members of ey debbie hanson and
i'm saying here tonight to um
explain the report in a little bit more
detail but just by way of um
introduction
um the the report that you asked to
consider tonight and provides the
preliminary audit conclusion in relation
to rochford district council's financial
statements for the year 2020-21
um
at the date of the report um ey have
substantially completed their audit of
the council's financial statements um
and currently they um are not expecting
there to be um any
um
significant matters to report um they
are expecting to issue an unqualified
audit opinion and a positive opinion in
terms of the council's value for money
arrangements
um
the
council is um obliged to prepare an
annual statement of accounts um and
those have been signed as true and fair
by myself um earlier in the year um in
line with the um the deadline of 31st of
july since that time the um the
financial statements have been available
online for um public um
review
as i said the account the audit is
substantially completed now um but given
that there's still some small
outstanding matters to conclude um
the recommendation in the report tonight
is that um the audit committee delegate
further um to the audit chair to do the
final sign off of the um
accounts
um once that audit work is completed
which we are hoping will be before
christmas
um
so at this point i'd probably hand over
to debbie to just um say a little bit
more about the audit process and the
report please thank you
thank you naomi um i will take the
report as read from my members and
therefore i won't take you through every
page of it which i'm sure you'll be very
pleased about but what i would like to
do is really just take you through the
executive summary um so members will
find that
starting it depends which page numbering
you're looking at but starting on page
numbering 6.8
of your pack um if you're using
electronic page numbers that's page 17.
so i just wanted to check
you on some changes in the scope of our
audit since we issued our audit plan um
so as always we update our materiality
once we get the draft financial
statements we've set out the figures
there in a table and we showed you
there's been a very small
change in the materiality levels that
we've set um compared to our planning
stage and that's actually increased our
materiality so that doesn't give us any
problems in terms of our audit
procedures
we also noted that as in the previous
year we've had to um accommodate the
impact of kovid 19 and remote working so
we've used um screen sharing teams etc
with the council to enable us to gain
assurance over the information that's
provided to us as part of the audit so
we refer to that as ipe
and so we have to undertake procedures
to confirm that's complete and accurate
and we've been able to do that
successfully
and then we've also identified a couple
of other increased risk areas not
significant risk but areas where we've
had to give additional focus to compared
to what we reported to in our plan the
first of those is in relation to the
recognition of grant income
related with kovid 19 and that's because
all local authorities have received
significant amounts of additional grant
funding due to covid some of that is
directly for the council's use some of
that is for the council to pass on to
third parties so that's a kind of agent
or principal decision
and that drives the accounting in the
accounts and then other other elements
of grant income have conditions attached
which again impact on the accounting for
that grants income so because of the
volumes um involved in that we've
identified that as an additional risk
for all of our audits this year
in addition has been a new accounting
standard which requires auditors to
undertake more work around key
accounting estimates so for the council
those estimates are generally around
your ppe valuations and also pensions
liability valuations so that has driven
some additional work that we've done in
those areas
so moving on to the next page as naomi
said we have substantially completed the
audit and the field work is now
substantially complete and we're just
working through a review so i've
actually been reviewing the file earlier
today
again as in previous years i'm really
pleased to note that as at the date of
drafting this report and the current
dates we haven't identified any
differences that we need to bring to
your attention and that's either
corrected or uncorrected
there have been some disclosure
differences and i'll just take you on to
explain one of those in a little bit
more detail in a moment but overall
again the accounts have been produced to
a very high standard i would say um with
very good supporting working papers
which in venezuela's to complete the
audit and quite efficiently i would say
once we've started that so thank you to
the finance team once again for all
their help
we've noted in relation to value for
money that has outlined in our plan and
there's changes to the code this year
which should change the work we've done
around that we've substantially
completed those procedures and again
haven't identified any risks or any
areas that would impact on the audit
opinion we will need to report you on
the work we've undertaken in that area
in greater detail but we'll do that in
the auditor's annual report now rather
than in this report which is where you
would previously have seen any
commentary
if i can then just flag to you at the
bottom of page 611
one issue that's a slight problem this
year again across all of our local
government audits is that the
instructions for the whole of government
accounts haven't yet been issued
as a result of that it means that we are
not able to confirm that the council is
below the threshold for wga which means
we cannot issue our certificate to say
we've completed all of our statutory
responsibilities so there's no impact
from that on the actual audit opinion we
issue it just means we can't issue our
statutory certificate but we will do
that as soon as those instructions are
issued
if i can then take you onto the meet of
the report so 612 is where we highlight
the risks that we identified and the
status of that work i won't go through
each of the risks but the the work is
concluded in all of those areas now um
and we haven't identified any
significant issues
um we have identified um some changes we
would like made to go in concern
disclosures and that primarily just
relates to timing differences so since
the accounts were produced the council
has made some decisions around its
subsidiary green gateway and as a result
the disclosures in the accounts in
relation to that subsidiary will just
need to be updated and to refer to that
in relation to the granting complaint we
referred to we have identified a few
grants where there is a potential
misclassification in terms of whether
the income should be recognized in the
income expenditure account or whether
there's a it's a receipt in advance
because all the conditions haven't yet
been met and we expect the council will
amend for those changes they're really
just sort of classification so there's
no impact on the bottom line from any of
those issues that we've identified
i wasn't proposing to go through in any
more detail as i said it's been a fairly
smooth audit very few issues to report
um
but very happy to take any questions or
any comments on anything within the
report or any other matters
thank you
debbie's the chair and i don't know if
you want to just open up the um
up to any questions that anyone might
have
yes uh
are there any questions and and thank
you debbie
i don't see anybody putting together
my hand
my hand has disappeared
okay that's the height
council smith has indicated before me
though
if that's all right
yeah i i i'd just like to say um
how pleased i am with with these
findings
and um
it goes without saying i hope everyone
will be able
to agree with that it's a a great
reflection on the team that naomi
works with and the team that naomi leads
and um
almost as always she needs to be
congratulated on the on the work that's
been produced and and
independently examined so i i would like
to thank her for this thank you
yeah yes uh thank you i agree with that
um oh i do have councillor dre now
before councillor high
thank you uh chairman uh just uh an
observation um really i note that uh
there are the normal checks and balances
in respect of the fraud risk
but is regular updated training given to
staff so that they can
readily identify
fraud
um if i find my
chair and
i don't know actually if i might want to
oh sorry
i think it's a slight delay um
yeah i was going to maybe um refer to um
mike porter if that's okay um
um as our chief audit um executive but
um
yeah yeah i mean we do do regular
training um
uh on um sort of governance and fraud
issues obviously some specific areas
within the council where that is um
focus so in particular in our kind of um
revenues and benefits team there's
particular offices with responsibility
for um particularly for forward
detection and and they will have um
training but we we have um
uh some wider training that is um
delivered across the council as well um
i don't know if there's anything else
you wanted to say in terms of that
michael jim
oh yeah i'm aware that council has a
fraud e-learning module um
which we're in the process of revisiting
updating but that's mandatory training
for officers of the council so as part
of my role i'll be i'm taking a refresh
of that um
e-learning module at some point in time
in the next few months then rolling that
out to staff i know also you can be
assured as part of our own work we have
a view to fraud as part of all the all
the engagements we undertake
so yeah
thank you
are you happy with that counselor dry
yes thank you chairman
councillor hi and it appears your hands
now working yeah i found it thank you so
i think my doc's about to start howling
in a minute so apologies for that if she
does um if it it's really and i noted
the comments saying that it was a very
smooth audit
i would probably disagree with that
given that it's been
the the delays
that
we've encountered with it
and i think this is now the third delay
um
i'm
i
i mean the the reasons for this have
been explained to me before and pre in
previous years
um
and just to put this in there a leader
from another council
um
who i saw today did say he was
considering asking for money back from
their auditors because they're delayed
so i understand this is not just a
rockford issue it's it's a national
issue
what
in reality what
from our auditor for this year what
should we expect
next year and ongoing years i'm i know
it's not just an ernst young
problem or an ey problem
um and i just
would like to get a handle on what our
expectations should be in future
we are paying for a service
but the service we get isn't what we pay
for because the deadlines aren't met but
i just want i just want a feeling if
they think yes this is going to carry on
until the legislation changes or
or until more people are recruited are
people coming into the audit field for
local authorities i just want a feel if
this is going to go on for another three
four years
or they think it might be getting better
in a couple of years
okay i'll answer i think there's two
elements that question
first of all like to pick on upon the um
the point that we're providing a service
we we are providing the service but it's
a statutory um required service and
although there are timetables um that we
target ultimately um an audit opinion
sign-off cannot be driven by a deadline
debt because an opinion can only be
issued when it's safe to do so when
sufficient work has been undertaken to
issue that opinion
to work any other way would basically
compromise the independence of the audit
which is absolutely crucial to giving
you and the members of the public the
assurance over the audit opinion
having said that i fully recognize that
obviously we are not where we want to be
in terms of the timetable this year we
had originally scheduled the audit to
start much earlier with the aim of
signing off by the end of september
unfortunately due to staffing changes as
we note in the audit results report from
from our side not from the council side
um and also ongoing pressures from
delayed 1819 and 1920 audits we had to
make a difficult decision to move that
audit to be able to resource it properly
with an appropriate team and to be able
to complete it in a reasonable time
frame
hence my comments about the audit having
gone smoothly reflect the fact that when
we have been able to start the audit
with an appropriate team the audit has
gone very well i think and the officers
have been able to support us
as they always do um you know very
positively in terms of responding to
queries and providing working papers
in response to your question about what
the future holds in terms of the likely
timetable for next year
we've put quite a lot of work into
scheduling for next year with the m
completing all of our audits by the end
of december um i can't remember exactly
where um roxford is in that schedule at
the moment we are trying to obviously
pull more of our audience forward but we
recognize that we and other firms cannot
move from the position we are now
to completing all of our audits by the
end of september next year that is just
physically impossible because of the
position we are in now we would normally
have been doing our planning before
christmas maybe maybe sort of doing some
walkthroughs and then doing early
substantive work in the new year
and we're not in a position to do that
yet
so i don't think we'll be normalized by
the end of december 22 but i would think
that by the end of december 23 we should
be back to a normal position and that is
what we're targeting to do so some
normalization by next year and i would
hope by december 23 um things will be
back to a
more sensible position across all and as
you say this is not just a rockford it's
not just an eye position it's a
sector-wide and it's influenced by a
number of factors and and i don't think
any of us can
ignore the impact that covert has had on
the audits for the last two years both
in terms of additional work required but
also the impact of remote working not
being in
able to in the same room as an audit
team and also with your your finance
team as well so i think it's been a very
challenging time all round in terms of
the impact it has on the work that we're
undertaking
thank you um there doesn't seem to be
anybody else's hand up for
um to ask a question
so members at paragraph 8.1 on page 6.3
there are four recommendations
item one and item four are for noting
items i will take those first
item one that the contents of the draft
audit results reported
reports be noted
is that noted members i did
agree
i did
thank you
item for that the mo
movement in general fund balances be
noted is that noted members
noted noted
thank you
members i will move recommendations two
and three from the chair do i have a
seconder
yes chairman thank you
thank you councillor macpherson
right number two
that the financial statements be
approved in principle
and number three that the final sign off
of the financial statements be delegated
to the chairman of the audit committee
subject to no significant audit changes
being identified post the committee
meeting
are you happy to vote on block for
recommendations two and three
agreed
yes
i i assume that's agreed then there's no
raised icons so
that's agreed
kevin we will need to uh we will need to
formally vote on uh on on the two
recommendations though please
yes so
um
please unmute yourself now and tell me
if you're not able to use the electronic
hand
so
members if anyone would like a recorded
vote to be taken please click on the
raise hand icon
gentlemen i'm raising my hand
yes councilman pearson you want a
recorded vote
uh
no chairman sorry my electronic hands
not working the same thing
my mind's gone off as well but i can
press alt and why and it'll work
okay thank you
right so all those
so we're gonna do
a felt my electronic show of hands
apart from
councilman and councillor fd
i think i'm getting working press
ultimately all those in favor of the
recommendation
you're pressing sorry
autumn white
alt and why
or
alt and why thank you
so please click on the raise hand icon
once
uh
chairman of um if members can please
lower their um their electronic hands
it's autumn why to lower it as well joe
thank you couldn't see at this end
so
the chairman um if if um if you could
ask people um those that want to vote
against please
yes um does anyone want to vote against
please raise your hand
[Music]
there any abstentions please
so any abstain any against know your
hand and those wishing to abstain
abstain please click on the raise hand
icon
right
i understand that is
approved
seven for
known voted against not abstained
thank you everybody
right we now move to item 7
audit progress report 21
22.
mike porter the chief audit executive
will introduce the report
you very much
thank you um hopefully you can hear me i
do seem to have some problems with sue
with uh an unstable internet connection
um but hopefully you can all hear me
if i can first of all direct members to
um
7.3 of the agenda pack
since the last committee in september
the team have completed a further five
audit engagements
three of those engagements received an
adequate assurance opinion and two of
those engagement we didn't actually
provide an opinion as such
if i can deal with those um two
engagements where no opinion was
provided
one relates to housing benefits subsidy
where we undertake work on behalf of the
external auditor
and that's bdo for housing benefits
subsidy so um jim
is undertakes a sample of testing
whereby we test the accuracy of a sample
of housing benefits in payments
that work then feeds into the overall
work of the external auditor in terms of
their overall assessment of the housing
benefits subsidy that we claim back from
central government
if we if we find some errors ourselves
and then that then calls for additional
work by the external auditor
and this is a piece of work that we
undertake every year on behalf of the
external officer
um the other um audit engagement that
also we didn't provide an audit opinion
on was the consultancy to see um piece
of worker requested by the service
department
um where we looked at the work of the
planning and building control
technicians
so with this piece of consultancy where
we were looking at suppose a lien
assistance type approach were there any
benefits to be had were there any
duplication of effort
and both those areas had been subject to
a lean review a couple of years ago so
we didn't actually find many areas where
the service could be improved
um so yeah
that i think the overriding issue was
probably perhaps a lack of resource in
that area but we couldn't find any areas
where there's duplication or effort or
or things weren't working as we expected
it um coming back to the three audit
engagements where we provided an
adequate assurance billion these audits
related to car parking
um engagement
and also we did some further work around
housing benefits the findings in
relation to these three pieces of work
and provided appendix 2 to this report
and and that
starts at 7.10
um
now moving on in terms of um dealing
with counter fraud activity
counter fraud is basically um undertaken
by the compliance team within the
reference press and ben's service
and as you can see from my report at 7.3
they continue to make considerable
considerable savings in relation to
council tax
and business rates
moving on if i may um the last area i'd
like to bring to members attention is
the worker service departments in
addressing internal audit
recommendations
um at the moment we only have 13 live
audit recommendations
um seven of those are new wrecks since
the last audit committee in september
all i would add is since the last
committee in september to the
recommendations that had their dates
revised
um i'm quite happy to thank any
questions in relation to my report
are there any questions members
yeah sorry my computer's going slow with
me pressing on things
i don't see anybody ask wanting to ask a
question
so
members at paragraph 8.1 on page 7.2
there are three recommendations which
are all for noting
number one that the update on delivering
the
2021-22 audit plan be noted
number two that the conclusions and
results from completed audit engagements
in appendices 2 and 3 be noted
and number three that the updated status
of audit recommendations in appendix
four be noted
is that noted members
noted chairman no no change okay thank
you
hey thank you
thank you
so i will move on to a gen
sorry did somebody say something
no
i will move on to agenda item eight
review of the council's risk register
2021-22
naomi lucas assistant director resources
will introduce a report
thank you chair
um yeah the the
this report and presents um the six
monthly review of the council's risk
register
um which was last presented to audit
committee in july 2021
um
it sets out all the key risks that are
faced by the council and together with
the controls that are in place to
mitigate those risks and an assessment
of whether each is considered to be high
at medium or low risk
this is further supported by
service risk registers
which are available on request
um
the risk on the corporate risk graduate
register cover both day-to-day
operations and new projects and
initiatives that are required to achieve
the council's business plan
so since the last audit committee um the
leadership team has um as i said um
conducted a review of um some of the
risks which are set out at um
paragraph 4.5
um of those the only changes that have
been made are to update um
the level in terms of the adequacy of
controls for risk 3b which is health and
safety um which are now considered to be
good rather than fair as a result of
further improvements in procedures and
training across the service areas
however members will note that that risk
is still marked as a higher residual
risk overall and that is because and
despite the mitigations that are in
place the impact um this risk in that
area could have is still much as high
which leaves it with an overall scoring
of higher still
in terms of other risks have been
updated risk 11 in terms of partnerships
has been revised to reflect the
contractual elements of the risk um and
the and the controls um
and the risk mitigation plans which um
has improved the annual score of those
controls to good
um
the other risks that were reviewed this
time around did not result in any and
any updates being made to the corporate
risk register
um so as i mentioned earlier there's a
few risks that have a high residual risk
rating remaining um of which one of
those is health and safety which i
already mentioned
and the other two that are still marked
as high risk are
risk nine which is around months budget
um
uh which is in common with most of the
local authorities the council obviously
faces significant financial challenges
over the medium term
so um the overall risk of that is still
considered to be high
um and the other one is risk 10 which is
an inability to agree to return retain
staff
um which again although it can be
mitigated to a degree through the
council's people plan
um remains high due to the fact that as
a small council we do sometimes struggle
to compete with larger
councils and the private sector to
recruit and retain staff so that the
residual risk of that remains high
um i think that's probably all i draw
members attention to at this point um
but obviously happy to try and take any
questions if anyone has any thank you
chair
if you can raise your hand if you've got
any questions please
counselor mrs mason
thank you chair um there's a couple of
questions i'd like some
further clarity on
i've seen the risk register often but
what has always concerned me about it is
that it's very subjective
uh rather than objective
um have the officers um attempted or
could they attempt to see if in some of
these areas we could put a more
numerical quantity on
the impact so that so that we have some
objectivity i mean we can put the
likelihood is two three or four i can
understand that but
it doesn't seem to be
very objective so i i have concerns over
that which i've i know i've expressed
some years ago it doesn't seem to have
altered i appreciate the difficulty
and the
second um
issue is
we have now got three areas of high risk
and i realize that there's very
justifiable reasons for that but
i wonder
what activities are going to be done to
get that risk level down and i'm also
concerned to see that all the other risk
levels are medium we've got no low risk
which um is a little concerning
thank you council mr mason chair i may
i'll try and answer those questions
um yes so if i draw members attention to
page
8.21 which sets out the rescoring matrix
and that the
officers uh use in terms of
assessing the score of each individual
risk both in terms of the likelihood and
the impact of the event occurring
and i i do take on board that obviously
there is an element of subjectivity in
terms of determining both the likelihood
and the impact score that the guidelines
set out on that page do um attempt to
give um
some numerical kind of weighting to
those different score levels and for
example in terms of financial risk there
are some ranges of um financial cost
that would be associated with with each
risk which can be used to help um
identify where each risk should score so
i think that there is obviously as i say
some degree of subjectivity in terms of
that but the the risk scoring matrix is
meant to give officers a guide in terms
of how they score those risks
um in terms of the risks that remain
high um
as council mrs mason and said we
obviously do take as many actions as we
can to try and mitigate those um in
terms of the likelihood of
things occurring we can often take
actions to try and reduce the impact um
so that the one that i referred to
earlier in terms of health and safety
obviously the control levels are good
which um sort of reduces the likelihood
of an um an event happening but often it
what we can't control so much is the
actual impacts of of if that if that
risk were to occur
um so for example you know obviously in
terms of setting a balanced budget and
the financial risk um
if we couldn't set a balanced um budget
obviously that remains a kind of you
know high high risk for the council so i
i think there is obviously a balance to
be struck but we can't necessarily
always bring all risks down from from
high um but yeah as i say except that
there is
an element of um
of judgment with within that
um in terms of the risks that remain
medium overall which as you suppose the
majority of them
um in terms of how the scoring matrix
works unless again the likelihood and
the impact are both low
um it's unlikely that a risk would
remain low overall um and in some ways
you could argue that perhaps um in those
cases the risk doesn't actually want
being on the corporate risk register at
all so again i think that the nature of
the risks and
being strategic and corporate in nature
um means that probably they are those
that we can't necessarily manage down to
a very low level um which is why they
are on the risk register in the first
place um so i hope that sort of provides
some context for the questions
thank you chair i can come back um and
thank the officer for her clear
explanation and i accept that there is a
matrix there
but the matrix itself is in my view
subjective so
i do remain concerned that the
subjectivity of the risk level but i
accept that it's very difficult
to take subjectivity out of it thank you
thank you
councillor hi
thank you chairman
on
i think castlemason was asked one of the
questions i was going to ask and i've
asked before so i'll leave that one i'm
just going to a specific point on page
8.11 item five
about council held data is lost
disclosed on issues to detriment of
individuals or organizations
as
a result of any inadequate protection um
i've asked the question about this some
time ago
might be even pre pandemic um
because obviously there's a financial
consequence to this as well which is
clearly put out in the in the report um
i i have previously asked have we looked
at insurance for such an event insurance
is available for this and i want to know
if we did look at that or if we haven't
got around to it yet which might be
understandable given the pandemic
happened in between my question
originally and now
thank you councillor um yeah the quick
answer is yes we have considered it and
we have recently
um
we tended for our insurance provision um
and yeah cyber kind of insurance is one
of the areas that you rightly say there
is some cover available in the market
um however
i think there's a bit of a mixed opinion
um in terms of um the
kind of um actual adequacy of the the
cover that it can provide and it can't
necessarily ensure a way all risks
associated with cyber and um
i think um a lot of the risk is
associated with um
perhaps some of the reputational and
other aspects of such a breach occurring
um and obviously potentially um you know
in the worst case scenario um fines from
the ico etc and i think in most cases
insurance wouldn't cover those and it
will potentially cover
some of the direct costs of getting
systems back up and running um so our
broker and kind of didn't necessarily
recommend that we we took out that
insurance policy at this this this point
it's not something we've definitely um
taken off to the table in terms of
future considerations but i think there
is a bit of a mixed opinion amongst um
councils about whether
um that that cover can actually provide
value for money in terms of the the
coverage it would pay out if such an
incident were to occur so we have made
an informed judgment that we we chose
not to take it out at this time but i i
wouldn't rule out um considering it
again in the future thank you
um if i just may come back very quickly
on that one um
has a
have you looked for the risk register
and if it changes if you did take out
the insurance
and if you is that why you have decided
not to because you've done that exercise
um yeah so i suppose it's a bit of a
two-way street and we obviously
made a sort of broad-based risk
assessment of
the value of the insurance um policy i
mean you could argue that if we took it
out it would um you know provide another
level of control which potentially could
bring this score down slightly obviously
that's a judgment call in terms of the
cost that is associated with that as
well as i said i think the wider risks
around a breach of that nature would
potentially be um
some of the reputational risks and fines
etc which insurance itself can't really
cover so i think i think the the impact
on the um the uh yeah the scoring would
probably be reasonably limited
thank you
thank you
are you happy with that councillor hi
yeah very yeah no i'm happy with that
yes thank you
thank you uh councillor meown
uh my question is just really about uh
risk assessments and the kind of
methodology of it
obviously we have a kind of background
of incident rates or something occurs
we can log that
and obviously
there are different forms of risk so
when you talk about matrix
i'm
not at all sure how
this works in practice because some of
it can be subjective opinion other
things can be based actually on the
double entry bookkeeping
and other things and checks
but when we talk about a matrix a risk
can affect the organization can affect
individuals and so on so i'd like to ask
you really is is there somewhere where
we can get some detail of actually how
this process
uh operates or is it more subjective and
then we make notes about it in pacific
areas that's uh i mean it's not so easy
as a risk assessment that a building
might fall down if you slam the door and
who would be at risk it's not quite like
that
um so
but it it occurs to me that obviously if
the methodology is good it enables you
to set a strategy to correct things
which you're obviously trying to do
i know part of this is probably a
training issue and partly procedure
but i've got a little bit interested in
this so uh you know i realize you
probably won't be able to give a full
answer tonight but is there somewhere we
can
uh can look and actually um
actually look at this area because it's
uh you know it is an interesting area
and it can if it goes wrong cause uh
quite uh concerning effects uh and that
that's all my question is really
um yeah thank you cancer now
um yeah so the council does have a risk
framework that it operates within and
that was reviewed um probably two or
three years ago now in conjunction with
one of the council's insurers zurich who
came in and did an independent review
and did carry out um some training and
sort of um help facilitate the um
refresh of the council's corporate risk
register um i think that is due for
another refresh probably over the coming
year um so we are intending to carry out
another review of the corporate risk
management processes and it's obviously
tries to try and move us along the kind
of maturity curve if you like in terms
of where we are in risk management so we
probably will be bringing in some
independent facilitators to tell us with
that exercise again and i believe that
we will be bringing back a report to
audit committee later in the year to um
update members in terms of what that
looks like
um so hopefully that sort of provides a
bit of assurance to you in terms of the
how we've sort of got to where we are at
the moment and the fact that it is kind
of regularly reviewed and if there are
significant changes in terms of the way
we use our risk matrices um as part of
that process obviously that would be
brought to members attention and we
would um yeah um detail that in the
reports
it'd be interesting to see how that
kind of operates not to be intrusive
about it you know but it's just uh
particularly of interest to this
committee because you always feel you're
not totally empowered in audit because
you've got
not all of us are expert accountants and
so on so it's just just from that point
of view but that that's uh yeah thanks
for that and
i mean i could look forward possibly to
um having a look at that later perhaps
next year you know
i mean possibly it's something that
could be put onto a members training um
sort of requirement list if you like and
we could run a session particularly on
that probably after we've done the
refresh if that is a particular area of
members kind of
concerned that they'd like some specific
training on that area
yeah thanks very much
all right
thank you there doesn't seem to be any
more any further questions
so i'll carry on at paragraph 13.1
on page 8.3 there is one recommendation
that the content of the corporate risk
register for
one twenty two be noted
is that noted members
no coaches
that's noted
so that concludes the business for this
meeting
thank you all for attending the meeting
thank you i'd like to thank the internal
auditors for all their hard work the
meeting is closed at twenty twenty
and i wish all in every